[Musique]
et avec cette séquence on se rapproche
dangereusement de mon info qui concerne
nabila et à magali béria dans un instant
tu vas vraiment quelqu'un de love island
qui était annoncé sur la plateforme
amazon près
oui une info qui va vous bouleverser
voir vous bouleversifiant je pense que
vous allez partir à je pense que la
honte sur vous mettre tel que vous allez
plus pouvoir sortir du tout dans la rue
et c'est pas à cause du virus ce sera à
cause de vous allez on va avancer avec
koh lanta 21e saison avec des scores
étonnamment pas terrible franchement
alors pas terrible on est là ça se
stabilise à 4,5 millions de
téléspectateurs faut rappeler que la
semaine dernière il y avait aussi les
césars qui étaient en face qui ont fait
plus de deux millions six cent mille
téléspectateurs
c'est je pense un rythme de croisière
qui était pris pour cette émission
effectivement revanche qui est en baisse
d'audience par rapport aux saisons
précédentes quand même le souligner
alors comme chaque année on découvre un
casting on découvre un casting
d'aventuriers de vrais rebelles
devraient rendre l'eau de la vie des
gens qui sont dures forts qui vont
pouvoir assumer pleinement cette
aventure extrêmement difficile et puis
bah ça dure pas longtemps
regardez j'espère vous apporter toute
mon énergie physique déjà parce que j'ai
de la chance d'arriver très en forme
je sens bien qu'à quelque chose qui ne
peuvent pas parce que
superman dans l'estomac je sais pas je
peux pas vous laisser sur le corps dans
cet état là pour l'instant je vous
propose de vous ramener ou vous récoltez
benoît lui il est au plus mal
tenaillés par la faim 5 comment je vous
propose de vous amener à la clinique on
va regarder un petit peu les paramètres
vitaux voir comment tout se passe bien
de volontat au début c'était assez rare
que les candidats soient internes
auraient on a besoin que maintenant
c'est un peu comme quand vous jouer à
chat perché ceop
je me perds ça n'affirmerais et ils
prennent comme ça des boissons
énergétiques du jus d'orange et pour moi
je pense peut-être pour vous ça fausse
un peu
est ce que ce jeu c'était une aventure
et de gens qui doivent suivre l'aventuré
que si on est blessé ben malheureusement
ça fait partie des règles et on doit
abandonner et non pas revenir et à
l'algérie qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mais sont très intelligents parce que
denis brogniart a dit qu'à chaque fois
qu'ils partent à l'infirmerie
le médecin leur donne des boissons oui
mais bon les requinquer donc forcément
dès que j'ai un petit peu fatigué là bas
je vais à l'infirmerie
c'est plus que c'est plus collante en
abyme qui peu l'image justement du
programme à ce que quand on parle de koh
lanta on a toujours envie va le
dépassement de soi comme vous le dites
avec cette image sportive familiale et
on n'est fait on se dit qu'on a un petit
peu une petite arnaque car on a surtout
l'impression que cette année le casting
il est très faible et que la production
elle a fait plus du marketing avec son
casting on est passé de la télé
aventuriers à la doua télé-réalité -
comme c'est la télé réalité je regarde
pas trop
qu'en pense mais tu m'aimes bien sûr
pernikoff ouais je vois l'évolution
c'est comme toutes les émissions c'est à
dire qu'avant on est pour se surpasser
c'était une aventure humaine
les gens étaient pas forcément au départ
très musclé lice musclée au fil des
saisons au fil du temps et on le voyait
à l'intérieur du programme c'est plus
une aventure humaine c'est effectivement
si la téléralité moi ça m'a vraiment
attiré latérite
moi je suis un peu mal placé pour en
parler non mais moi je regarde plus là
mais c'est vrai que koh lanta était pas
vraiment classé dans la télé dans le jeu
d'aventuré et et de survie c'est
vraiment un jeu de survie trek
maintenant bon le casting un peu plus
haut en couleurs on va dire n'est ce pas
vers l'or moi j'aime bien les nouveaux
candidats
elle pense à ces postes zélie toute
façon s'ils sont mauvais dans l'aventuré
koh kong et si tu te crées ne pourra
jouer ouais même temps qu'il sorte et
oui c'est vrai que pour reprendre ce que
vous avez dit le niveau des candidats
vous allez vous énervez longtemps vous
croyez votre crème des candidats sont
pas d'âme d'un grand niveau d' aventure
là ils sont très soulagé parce qu'il est
le retour des héros et drake le héros
il sait reconnaître du manioc à une
carotte et oui regardez si vous sauver
là aujourd'hui la tous les faits moussa
il a été immédiat c'est entre guy manioc
roi
sa théorie est pas de son monde et
nourrit ses nouveaux coéquipiers
un très bon point
[Musique]
tiens de panier qu'on achète en boîte de
conserve la mûre et ils font du coeur
merci
objectif rempli manioc régler tout ça
trop clean pour le monde forcément mais
sous sol mais si on a presque
l'impression que si apam moussa qui
arriveront jeudi ne mange rien mangé des
cailloux sur la plaza et c'est tout oui
alors quand est ce qu a voulu parler
oui alors je donne la parole bah merci
c'est gentil moi j'ai l'impression d'un
an koh lanta c'est les fragiles en
vacances c'est à dire que limite ils
vont là bas pour goûter des milkshakes
et dès qu'il y en a un qui a une petite
baisse de tension
il demande à aller à l'infirmerie non
avons les prenaient en exemple je sais
pas si vous vous rappelez moi je me
rappelais de chacun des noms des
aventuriers de koh lanta et on est bon
on va faire comment clémence la même
c'est formidable bravo elle nous a
impressionnés mais ils ont été pleins me
dire on s'en rappelle encore on se
rappelle de ses prouesses à koh lanta
alors même qu'ils n'étaient pas resté
très longtemps parce que c'était
vraiment des personnalités particulière
et là c'est un peu bad et des faibles
tout à fait à l'époque de moundir
c'était plus une émission aventurière
plutôt que maintenant c'est plus une
émission de télé réalité
je pense qu'avec le fil des années ça
c'est du scoop vous avez hâte et de
regarder programme oui sans moi je rate
pas où il met autant de monde hier je le
regarde et je loupais pas et vous qu'est
ce que blaise quel côté aventure pur et
dur la difficulté faisait pas fan de soi
c'est samantha avant tout ce que le
sportif recharge fait pas dans une
émission comme celle ci alors c'est vrai
que cette année il ya des candidats qui
sont qui sont venus dans le jeu il avait
4 ans quand le jeu a été lancé en france
et là ils sont comme des fans
il ya un certain sam qui est fan de
theora c'était le tahitien qui s'est
ouvert lui prend à lui pour un cure dent
si ce n'est pas un poisson
c'est le mag est mort c'est avec son nom
du fait un couteau passé alors il est
totalement l'admiration on peut le
comprendre
regardez donc préparé des bâtons pour
faire
une menace à présent étaient ou avaient
fait une assez un poisson en 2011 1 re
adjointe
alors pour vous dire que pour moi c'est
un de mes aventurier a préféré c'est un
exemple pour man 20 défaites et pas
forcément dur nawel mais c'est vrai que
l'été aura été beaucoup plus rapide ciel
ce qui m'a juste un petit peu énervé
c'est qu'elle dise j'ai pas peur de lui
elle était trop sûre d'elle à savoir que
theora c'est quand même un des meilleurs
aventuriers de l'histoire de koh lanta
et qu'elle dise en plus devant tout le
monde mais je n'ai pas peur des terroirs
plus à la fin il a mis une bonne radio
qui est très tiki vraiment très content
de rencontrer et evra est alors vous
allez voir quand il parle de moussa on a
l'impression qu'il a rencontré madonna
depuis que moussa est arrivé mon
aventure à changer vous prévoyez un
guerrier qui arrive sur le camp et c'est
un grand personnage que j'aime beaucoup
et nous sommes
[Musique]
je vous trouve un peu dur parce que
j'aime bien ce casting parce que
justement on peut s'identifier galère
ils sont nuls ils sont c'est moins
accueillante dans koh lanta on vient
voir des gens qui savent pas résister le
dépassement qui savent comment faire
pour lutter contre le verrou demandé le
dépassement de soi justement qui ont par
de bas plus on peut cette fois l'ebitda
fin même si vous regardez la kindle fire
du format il ya de plus en plus dans le
glas de plus en plus de stratégie mais
il ya de moins en moins d'épreuves
physiques et sportives moi ça me est-ce
que vous êtes vous savez pourquoi ça
coûte moins cher à mon avis il ya dû y
avoir une réception de budget je pense
qu'il me demandait ce qu'on appelle des
hubs et accède en droit ou en fait tous
les tournages du monde entier se
succèdent et à mon avis je pense que
pour l'action de production d'ailleurs
il ya plus de caméras quasiment 24 24
mais c'est plus seulement tout filmé
trois huit ou dix heures par jour donc
sa chance quand même la façon de filmer
et de remplir son son programme